thank you diana is not here but I wanted
to thank him for heroic likes apparently
three-hour marathon and I also wanted to
thank you for staying and stick him for
such a long day and I also want to thank
Dan for this fantastic home Brook idea
that Mike just raised and I wanted to
make a disclosure I had a learning
breakdown that's the second slide of
Dance flexion today and it's not dance
fault it is my fault because I am my
flaws and you ha and sometimes ideas do
not come to me easily but there was
another little problem Mike you just
raised it there was letter H here and
the size of H was too small for my eye
and as a result I got another learning
breakdown and could not follow that how
many of you today understood every cent
that was presented nobody so each of you
had a learning break down at some point
similar to mine it makes me feel better
each of you had learning breakdown at
some point right okay and how many of
you had learning breakdown while
preparing is a flip pass that I had you
had learning break that yeah good
question
how many people actually prepared the
flipped class one two three four five
six seven eight
but you fail you fail preparing this
flip plus because flip plus assumes that
you provide feedback to me as an
instructor because if you and oh by the
way among 10 people who prepare the flip
how many of you experienced a learning
breakdown that remained an address
during pure flipped class know what you
break down is the following think let me
break down particularly in complex
discipline like mathematics or computer
science is when you go through lecture
like I then I went through a lecture I
had learning break down at some point
even though I teach this material smell
when you go through the lecture it goes
through the book when you go through the
research talk and you fail to understand
the speaker as a result since it's not
history or MIDI Middle Ages but
mathematics or computer science you
means if I miss fail to understand slide
two most likely I fail to understand
slide three and I fail to understand the
rest of this lecture
that's what call during break down did
you experience it but I'm I'm very proud
nobody experienced except for you maybe
right experience the learning breakdown
in my flipped class which means that you
should stop and go home what should we
do today
so what what is the proposal
since there is no loop learning
breakdown every single deal with this
but so that in the lectures that I would
like to learn more about good good
question but it doesn't make sense for
me to answer it because most people in
the class did not even take the flipped
class right now why you didn't take the
flipped class because you think that
online education line processes kind of
drunk route of Education right because
when I show up in the class and present
a lecture it is completely different
personal experience of connecting to
this teacher you can ask questions and
it's just much better right so I tell
all my students I think the two of them
survived until the very end too many
layers so I dropped out so I think it's
really really good to plug for the
hands-on part and I was submitting to
each other but so there are few things
we can do today I see like at least four
possibilities possibility month you go
home since there are no learning
breakdown possibility - I give a lecture
on genome assembly in class
possibilities 3 let me explain why I
won't do this you want to hear why I
won't do this but no ok
possibility 3 I can basically explain
why the traditional way my view the
traditional way I taught for all my
career and that they were exposed to
including myself above all my life
I sank it is junk food of Education and
I think that there is a much superior
way to learn and teach and in the last 3
years
I basically invested thousands of hours
into joining my teaching came to this
new way and it is against my principles
to give a classroom lecture I can give
research lecture I haven't done it I
classes at UCSD as a regular professor
in the last three years I haven't given
a single lecture ok the performance of
students in my classes significantly
improved probably because I'm a bad
teacher in my lectures were bad in the
first place but that's why when Ron told
me I originally thought that this boot
camp will be both more research driven
sent when Ron told me it should be
basically classroom lecture I told Ron
sorry I don't give classroom lecture
anymore I sent it as counterproductive I
think a drunk or a pretty good so they
can I can explain if you're interested
why seems the way we currently teach
represent junk-food of education or if
you want I can give more kind of
research dream and lecture for example I
noticed you do all have fantastic
conference on computational cancer
biology I notice that in this conference
we hardly talk about the past from past
tobert anti-cancer drugs they talk a lot
about what's happening in cancer how
genome sequencing relate and illuminate
our cancer studies but we don't even
touch on the question how genome
sequencing can lead to new anti-cancer
drug
and I can give this type of research so
suggest whatever you want
research research but let's vote let's
move
who wants to go home nobody ok give
intellectual in the class about genome
assembly is not an option
who wants to hear why I hate traditional
classroom lectures no good so let's go
to research labs that make it easy you
want to hear why I think traditional
classroom I know it takes 15 minutes a
place I'm sorry
yeah and who wants to hear this church
lecture so I simply and perhaps I'd
watch to me of course I can see hundred
percent right but so presidential
candidate I'm at liberty to express my
position on this matter okay alright
let's let's go how's it going to how
people
so again so I'm curious about how you
run flip classes and one of the
questions I would have about that would
be what do you do when you show up to
class and nobody's done before work okay
my class works like this I request
student to learn all the material before
the class and do homework before the
class
I knew my lecture time is too important
is too precious to give a speech in the
class I want to communicate with
students in the class know them by name
learn how they think if I spend 15
minutes of 45 minutes 7 allowing 5
minutes for question in my class it
means they don't know me they can press
a button and just listen to all my
lectures right I book in the class and I
ask students show me your thump if they
show thumblr exist it means I understood
everything by hundred percent this is
zero and this is everything in between
and then I went to the student and asked
what is your learning breakdown students
should formulate their learning break
down before selection student asking
question in the class I rate the quality
of the questions asked and students who
understood everything answer this
question so the class is completely
dialogue based and engage many student
so that's that's roughly how I run my
class and I can run it for a class of I
try it for the class for a class of 70
students I don't know is it scalable for
more but it's definitely scalable for up
to 100 students and this is not my ideas
that's how Google boot camps are run I
give them points for class participation
illusive questions asked or supposed
questions answered it's 20 percent of
their grade
no you don't need to come if you know
everything just take the example Ron I
have almost hundred percent attendance
in my classes okay because the
attendance and participation is part of
the yeah that's pretty good incentive of
course anyway should we start to this
more kind it's it won't be really
research lecture but at least more
advanced at classroom lecture
okay um Dallas is a best-selling soft
tissue sarcoma drug it is insulated from
siscri
and thousand kilogram of these clears I
need to easily at one gram of film
there's a lot of damage to nature turn
out yonder Ellis is not at fault
oh this note is not involved it's not
produced by the sister
it's produced by a non-ribosomal peptide
that generated by symbiotic bacteria
living on sis Craig and David chairman
made this breakthrough discovery
explaining what is actually producing
materials
why is it important because the early
dose of Yun Danis cost roughly fifty
thousand dollars if we are able to
synthesize this elusive compound it cost
may be reduced to twenty dollars however
how can we do this there are hundreds of
bacterial species living consists
squares which one producing dense and
here genome sequencing can send I be
able to solve this problem today with
all advances in genome sequencing
unfortunately not and I'm going to talk
about this now yond Ellis is just one
example of anti-cancer drug that is
represents so-called natural products
drugs that are basically bore route from
nature's like antibiotics and when we
talk about anti-cancer drug the usually
it bring poster example of Glivec that
works on Philadelphia Hamas all right
but the most potent anti-cancer more
than 50 percent of anti-cancer drugs are
drugs like um there's drugs extracted
from natural products they are produced
either by bacteria or East
sometimes they are produced by plants
and the question is how is it done and
what we can learn from
to greatly increase this spectrum of
drugs that already accounts for 50% of
anti-cancer drugs more than 50% of
undercuts and brings us back to
Frederick Sanger who actually got two
Nobel prizes
everybody knows about his Nobel Prize
for the enemy sequencing but in fact
many years ago his first Nobel Prize was
gained for protein sequencing and
amazingly enough say the office emblem
was somewhat similar also at that time
the assembly method were not really
develop everything was done by hand they
have amazing advances in DNA sequencing
that you will definitely cover we have
really really slow advances in protein
sequencing protein sequencing remains
very expensive and time-consuming
process today and I in this talk I won't
talk about protein sequencing I talked
only about genome sequencing but it's
important to keep in mind and when
things come to drugs it is very
important to move from DNA to protein
and see how this transition goes make
sense okay this is my talk from genome
sequencing to drug discovery and by drug
discovery I limit my attention to only
specific type of drugs drugs that are
produced by nature and I'm interested
only in one particular type of this drug
peptic products peptides or protein so
we made from immunised
and this year Nobel Prize was given
exactly for products like this this is
this amazing story you you two got Nobel
Prize who this Hirsch index include two
two she hardly published any research
papers and you notice that these are
people who started working quite some
time ago and it reflects a very slow
pace of discovery in this field it's
very time-consuming
now how possibly you you two
can discover any scent in 1967 in China
during the Cultural Revolution the story
goes like this
in 1967 washing in soldiers will drop
him dead at the hashemian trail it was
Malory infested pathway and horse Amin
asked martyrdom to develop anti-malaria
drug Mountain set up a secret research
project to develop a malaria drug in
1967 and you you two were sent two
thousand Challenger to malaria infested
area to do research on this merch or
Mallory anti-malarial drug her husband
of course was sent to the countryside to
labor camp
and her daughter was sent to our finish
so she started working and she found
fourth century ancient Chinese medicine
bomb script where this particular plant
I forgot the name was linked to
treatment of Mallory
he made us was supposed hot extraction
tested it and it did not work you didn't
stop her she continued reading another
four century manuscript hinted that
heart instruction is bad because it
didn't kills active ingredients maybe it
makes sense to make cold water
extraction should try called both
extraction tried it on herself and it
worked and that's how Chinese
anti-malarial drug that eventually got
Nobel Prize most about so what I will be
talking about in this talk I will be
talking about genomics and genome
sequencing in particular but it's
important to realize the drugs only will
come in the play if all these different
fields play together synergetic and i
will be focusing on this metabolomics
aspect of this but metabolomics i mean
pathetic product why it is so difficult
to sequence them well because they're
very exotic peptides not the appetites
that we kind of studied in traditional
biology book let me give you an example
of just one of such peptides also
natural product
so there's a theta defensive it's 18
amino acid long cyclic peptide which
represent a concatenate of nine amino
acid long peptides from two different
proteins in what biology book you read
about cutting exactly at the exact
position two peptides from different
proteins and then magically from two
different one concatenating them
together what enzymes do this work it's
a very important antimicrobial and hand
viral peptide pretty good because it's
prevent viruses from entering seven has
anti HIV activity this is a good news
the bad news is that macaques and
baboons have it but we don't and the in
chimpanzees don't and what happened so
this is a FD given n at a given Diaz
these two proteins from of each this
nine amino acid long segments are
extracted seven million years ago there
was a mutation in human that introduces
stop codon right before this nine amino
acid long peptide into one of them as a
result peptide is not being produced
we lost ability to make the defensinator
actually linked to more rampant HIV in
fact in infection in human is it clear
what happened it was it used to be
generated the german macaque but there
was a notation that changed something
came to stop codon returning to pursue
dodging okay
what's the evolutionary story for why
that was allowed exactly I'll come to
this so this is extremely
counterproductive for humid seemingly
unfortunate but for human and the
question is can we get say the defensive
back turn out that we can because there
are drugs that actually allows ribosome
to move so stop codon and continue
translated okay and in this way it was
shown that this treatment of this drug
we get our side the defensive back now
here comes the most interesting part of
the story obviously since we can get say
the defensive back all the some agent
machineries that cards peptide and
gluten together make John tap that into
cyclic exist in human what for if it is
a simple set of defensive that we need
and unfortunately lost it should
deteriorate Mike salsa from you see from
you see who actually found say the
defense in fifty years ago since there
are hundred such peptides that amazingly
complex exotically bill peptide in human
but there is no way for us to see them
today why for many different reasons
mass spectrometry doesn't see a single
cyclic peptide is they're invisible to
mass spectrometry how can you figure out
what is the database to search this
peptide against you have you have to try
every pair of possible peptide from the
human genome so this is examples that
represent the complexity of searching
for this natural products and example of
importance of searching for let me tell
you a little bit about the first
mass-produced natural product and it's
not penicillin the first mass-produced
natural product is Graham its side
Graham aside in Soviet which was
discovered in 1942 it looks like this it
doesn't look like through a traditional
cyclic peptide linear peptide it's
cycling and used
Soviet war spittle a year before
invasion of Normandy and Gao is a good
stallion prize that probably saved most
likely saved him from prosecution of
geneticists but listen guys he was the
only man in Russia in 1950s a long code
is nuclear physicists who could openly
speak against recent
so when Lybrand heat barrier came to
start him and told him the physicists
lead increases system biologists like
gaussian openly speak about leshenka
stalin told him make sure that our
scientists have everything needed to do
their job and edit anyway let's do tests
let's play flip class let's do tests
I'll tell you that this turret Terrace
item just enough made similar this
single bacteria bacillus brevis
generally 28 different types of
antibiotics single one production of
this type on antibiotics of anti-cancer
drug is usually take the largest genomic
footage in the genome the giant
machineries and very complex in ball I
can tell you that for bacillus brevis
machinery producing this hindu peptide
takes more space in nucleotide there's a
whole ribosome okay it's extremely
important for life of bacteria so these
are the signals okay okay the sequence
of amino acids and i ran it against the
genome to find what are 10 cards in
cording this denomination let's do this
you run it and we failed what happened
why did we fail to find this 10 codons
in quoting this 10 immunised no I there
is no modification here cyclic good so
we should try everything starting from
this considerable cyclic shifts right
and try all of them I didn't have
patience to show all 10 experimental
exists we will also fail it looks like
this tank add-ons disappeared from the
rhythm of what happened what can
possibly happen yes
no no error since the data it's like
model organisms every single sequence
perfectly no stop codon in the middle
what
no RNA editing no tumor symbol tablet
okay from wear-and-tear words translated
from
perfect they're coming thank you for
helping me so let me explain you how
amazing story of houses drugs
anti-cancer drug and antibiotics
I really built so they are raised on the
central dogma DNA makes RNA makes
proteins there is no other way in
biology book to assemble I mean acids
into proteins right ever cut room 63 got
Nobel Prize inhibits ribosome in but
civils brevis production of this peptide
continues how can it be
here comes interesting exam once the top
of central dogma there is another very
important process all don't ribosomal
peptide sequencing
some protein there are giant protein
that have ability to synthesize other
proteins without any help of wrappers on
without any carbons there are proteins
certain cult amino acids in another
protein
there's a giant molecular machines whose
only goal to make yet another Baptist
and that's why of course Tara Sidon is
not encoded in the genome
it's indirectly encoded in this giant
protein does it make sense we all be
exposed to this protein big time
starting from penicillin another drug to
this huge array this type of drugs count
not just 50% of anti-cancer drugs they
count for more than 60% of all drugs
there was the most successful type of
drugs ever invented by human actually
borrowed by human and antibiotics is the
most famous example but anti-tumor isin
agents like biomedicine there are many
many of them okay so but how is it done
how Parton can make another protein and
this I think is another that was
discovered 15 years ago I think it's
another Nobel Prize waiting
to happen my heart my hair made decode
amazing puzzle much more complex and
according genetic code let me briefly
tell you how it is done there is a giant
protein that may consist of 60,000
encode by sixty thousand nucleotides or
longer the longest known proteins and
this giant Millea it represents a giant
molecular assembly line
it contains suppose we want to seek to
synthesize a protein consisting of ten
amino acids it consists of ten demands
called adenylation diamond or a diamonds
and these demands one after another
slowly synthesized aiding amino acid to
each other ten I mean a citron chain and
finally matured it into cyclic okay and
and bacteria often spend like three four
percent of the entire genome doing this
enormous investment of energy and how is
it done there is amazing non-ribosomal
quote if you take this a demands
according four different terminations
you line them to it against each other
and you are ingeniously know what cones
to look at and here eight important
course or other columns are not
important then this a time in a shitload
code you could just for one minute the
cold kind of was cracked initially by
Mara Hill there are still active
research evolution of this code how it
turns how to adapt remains completely
very very open question ok what it has
to do with it
but good point
so the orphan centers are at one end in
assets plus 300 of amino acids just a
lot morning protein protein and Jenny
community right ribosomal but the right
Courtney team is just one of the most
popular non-standard feminized okay and
roughly maybe 20 30 % of amino acids in
this peptide are gone we're non-standard
okay what it has to do how does it
relate to drug discovery and in the last
few years there are following pipeline
emerges that like when you talk to a
natural product researcher and when they
talk about drug discovery spending three
years
one simply decoding non-ribosomal
peptide is considered normal
it's extremely slow process it's much
faster to sequence I don't know my mail
maybe already mammalian genome today
then to sequence the signal peptide
lysis so what do you do what currently
what is this pipeline generate mass
spectrum reads assemble genome from it
identify context containing this
molecular machine and RP sanitizers use
this ingenious non-ribosomal code to
predict what particular peptides this
machine generates and then you software
too much spectra against this predicted
code and that's what my lab have been
doing probably for seven more for almost
eight years now and there are nowhere
close to resolving this challenge so let
me explain why it is really challenge
actually we started Tristan just seventy
years ago was our first paper on the
topic so the challenge come from Yun
Dallas is an example of the challenge
you have to assemble through all this
this drug are produced by bacterial
communities these are not typically not
cultivated
bacteria you have to assemble method
Reena or single cell make sense and them
in meta-genome or single cell you have
to identify context contain Ian cannot
be synthetases good luck with that
because NRP synthetase just core of this
is 60,000 nucleotide long where did you
see metagenomic r assembly the press
context of the size hundred KB so it is
it is mainly captured but it is
fragmented as soon as fragmented it is
useless for me I cannot connect mass
spec obvious this NRP synthetase as and
as a result I cannot confirm any drug is
it clear what is the challenge the
challenge is how to make metagenomics
assembly or single cell assembly to turn
back complete genomes
and this is one of the matter bottleneck
in this line of research now that this
is this figure is for me it was
completely shocking because when I
started working in this area this
antibiotics national product discovery
was one of the last bastions of life
sciences practically untouched by any
computational algorithm innocent
completely innocent field and then David
chairman the guy who worked on a and
Ellis published a review and he showed
what it takes like it's basically
everything here metal-on-metal genomic
single-cell metabolomics all parts of
modern kind of different modern still
come together and they have to come
together for it to work they all should
work either lonely work talk to you
start talking about single sourcing in
this part I won't talk about a third
part because this is about genome
assembly basically okay so
four years ago I started single cell
development of single cell assembler I
was actually on sabbatical in st.
Petersburg and that was a desert there
was no single bioinformatics seminar of
course in the city of five million so I
came from my sabbatical and I found this
very very talented guys who came from
algebra selector computer science and
other fields that are not very well
suited the only things that kind of
United them the old were fantastic
products and I gave them presumably
unsolvable tasks to develop a new
assembly within a year no indications
were that they would fail but they
actually succeeded as they develop
spades assemblers that became very
popular and in the last year they were
focusing on scaling this assembler for
many different applications and meta is
here that is just one of these
applications and I wanted to tell you
about these challenges so this looks
like an advertisement this is actually
the first collaborative paper of this
lab that they publish just like in one
and a half EF the slab was form looks
like advertisement of bathroom equipment
but in reality isn't it called genome
research and it is about sequencing
bacteria in hospital
this is a huge problem because we can
only sequence bacteria to cultivate if
you want to cultivate takes time how to
make it instant check what is going on
in hospitals and that was basically our
first paper done it would be the Venter
Institute and why is this assembly of
single cells challenging I wanted to
explain and it kind of clarify who what
needed to be done in spades
there is order of magnitude difference
in coverage in single cell project due
to artifacts of amplifications
and existing customers implicitly or
explicitly assumes that coverage is
uniform like this like average is 600
along the entire genome and here
coverage varies by ceodore magnitude
talking about tariffs when coverage
varies you lose your ability to
distinguish errors from true segments
right so if we actually figure out how
to do this in 2011 and then the spades
and ID be AUD from University of Hong
Kong that kind of further develop this
and this is a solve problem we know how
to deal with this project which is very
encouraged what is more difficult
project is chimera grades and chimeric
reads in single cell projects maybe
toward of magnitude more frequent than
in normal projects this is a difficult
algorithmic problem that will require
forced networks careful analysis of
large graphs and that is basically
implementing this was one of the reasons
spades becomes successful because we
also learned that's a great number of
canary crates in normal projects and
usual assemblers don't pay don't pay
attention and deserve to this difficult
to not do this type of ventures so this
started as I said to the screen
pathogens in hospital and found amazing
coverage of pathogen in a bathroom often
very good hospital in San Diego not only
we found them we demonstrated that by
single cell sequencing we can assemble
nearly complete genomes this is 90
percent of coverage detecting creation
in crispers there are many things you
can learn just from a single cell no
time to grow the culture then they
started looking we're looking at
revealing the micro in
the dark matter of life in the different
paper and currently more than half of
bacteria clades never saw his sequence
they remain unciekin be calculated one
of this important clade is called km6 it
is everywhere and from the perspective
of 16s RNA nobody was able to sequence
it in the last 20 years and we were able
to capture in sequences genome they
introduced the approach called mini
meta-genome when we collect hundreds
single cells arbitrarily 400% events
make a mixture and try to sequence all
the genome at once so this is the
approach that sometimes look sometimes
doesn't work but we demonstrated 14:6 it
worked they captured it you know 90% of
all genes from this completely
previously unknown genome was
reconstructed and recently they
completely closed the single-cell
gentleman which is basically probably
the only case for single self genome
closing there are many excited I got
very excited in collaborations of this
project because in many exotic places
there is no way to go ahead but to these
single cells and this is Doug Barnett
who director James Cameron expedition
the process first batch chances data but
we don't still don't have this is from
Puerto Rico Trench we still don't have
deep sea expedition but Canada is still
in pipeline and of course we worked on
natural products and anti-cancer drug
with this various research but there's a
single cells is this electively simple
let me talk in the remaining time about
what to do this meta Jahnavi is a huge
challenge so but before let me tell you
what space space is of course de Bruin
graph assembler and if you would cover
the fit class you would know this but
I'm sure in this audience everybody
knows it anyway and there was no
shortage of de Bruin assembly
when we started working on space the
only problem was that now none of them
worked on single-cell data because of
this artifacts and as you know assembler
is a rather complex algorithmic and
software implementation challenge and we
basically rewrote all of all models of
assembly and implemented them in the
very exciting algorithmic challenges in
well-defined computational problems
something that I don't have time to talk
about here then we tried it on
single-cell and no surprise it greatly
outperform conventional or something so
space is now massive default method of
choice for assembling single cells and
it is amazing in 2000 when they started
like four five years ago video breaking
could be stopped biologists ansible to
get access to single-cell dataset now
there are a thousand of single cell
being sequenced every month so and then
when we applied to standard multi cell
dataset we were pleasantly surprised to
see that it actually outperform which is
relatively small margin but still
outperform the standard assemblers why
because there are actually some
variation coverage because the rank
Americ reads and we pay attention to
this and then we decided during the last
couple of years to transform space into
Universal assembler for there are ten
different types of assembly in different
tools I use four different types of
assembly so we tried for RMA assembly
and for all other purposes but I do
focus attention to metagenomics assembly
because this is more most relevant to my
interest in natural products and
basically red line here is space and
this is cumulative length of an longest
context in the assembly
so if you take context order them from
longest to shortest and compute
camisoles for 20,000 longest can take
account for 300 mega bases and very
quickly the Lord that actually spades
improved on an existing customer and the
more complex is the data set the more
dramatic is the quality this is dramatic
quality and somebody's soil data sets
are typically very complex why is it
happening actually it was not a surprise
for us because metagenomics dataset
feature
enormous variation in coverage and they
spent two years preparing to deal with
this variation coverage the req America
leads all type of artifacts and
afterwards we started developing many
branching into many different types of
assembly for example actually the first
course assembly of papaya and Oxford
nanopore Italy's Illumina Verdun with
spades model called hybrid spades but in
the remaining whatever remaining ten
minutes I will talk about recent very
exciting development should be 2016 here
which is true specs
who heard about true Centennial all
creeds the new technology from Illumina
one person okay then I do explain - okay
then I will explain how it works so you
will know about long crates the launch
button accurate that have 15% error rate
you know today generate long creat 10k
balloon that have error rate that is 150
times smaller than the error rate and
back pirates so let me explain how it
works imagine imagine that you can break
your genome into Hillis a human journey
into 10 KB pieces
then collect once again randomly 300 of
these 10 KB pieces and assigns them a
single barcode so you take 10 KB random
pieces from human genome 600 of them and
they a barcode it together afterwards
you don't need to assemble the whole
journey you only need to assemble a
single barcode right and that's what you
do so this instead of like all set of
rates your reads are separated into
barcodes its Illumina reads and after
you assemble this barcode you got
virtual reads that explains this barcode
so single barcode assembly is
essentially assembly of 310 KB long
segments the total length is 3 mega
bases how different it is from
assembling a bacterial genome of size 3
mega base so the due to this technology
we suddenly reduced a very complex
problem of analyzing human genome from
Illumina reads to problem of analyzing
single barcodes and Illumina generate
many many barcodes and a single
experiment in a single experiment they
cover 1 billion nucleotides actually
short of the human gene and why spades
is a good assembler process here's an
illustration so for single cell if you
look at single cell and you look how
many positions in the genome have
coverage 50 half average fabrics have
averaged modified coverage is everywhere
in difference from standard assembly
where coverage almost everywhere is 200
right I will show you so take a look at
this and I will show you here how the
coverage for barcode assembly look like
it's almost like identical picture so
being you already how to do this
that's why we're applying this and there
are unique into strength kinetic
challenges in this assembly that are
caused by amplification artifacts we
also had two years to prepare for
dealing with this it doesn't mean that
we had nothing to do developing these
are quite special truths in tiny clone
crates artifacts that have to be taken
into account it took us one year to
develop the assembler here's the result
but let me digest it for you because
there are too many numbers 80% of the
span of the barcode is covered by
virtual reads of lands at least 1 point
5 KB with the percent of full 10 KB
segments that were generated during the
practical result in virtual reads of
runs at least a KB small number of
assemblers that we can verify through
human genome and extremely high accuracy
of base calling 10 times more accurate
than standard Illumina reads okay
so you park that 310k no no 300 segments
each of one's 10 KB over lenses three
million nucleotide it's a tiny portion
of human genome it's only one thousand
of the human gene so we have single
barcode 300 segments say all over the
place right but so you have 300 so I'm
currently talking about assembly of a
single barcode as a way to generate long
creats Blanc virtual rates so I have 310
KB which is 3 megabytes it's small how
many of those I generate in a in a
single experiment so am i but this is
not all
so I actually generated Illumina read
for barcodes and instead of alumina
original short reads I generate let's
say 150 long let's say 8 KB reads but
simply assembling this small genome
vision barcode a single alumina kid has
384 barcodes
which account for short of the human
gene so simple experiment generate this
8 KB rates somewhat sample in there from
this rate in a single experiment
okay okay so but an easy way to think
about this sink forget about how
barcodes are generated this technology
will generate for you in a single
experiment huge number or Fried's most
of them are 8 KB long and extremely in
each of them is extremely accurate so
it's if we want to just abstract from
extra mental details be randomly sample
from the genome a KB sentence it does
they do not cover human genome entirely
they cover only short so you need
probably to run this ten times but you
don't have like crazy hungry text
coverage of human genome because the
reads are so long and so accurate
you probably will be this significant
cuts modest coverage according to London
Waterman formulas in the reeds are so
long and so accurate we probably will be
ok this average 5x for this type of
because in a single experiment in single
kit you don't do a single bar code you
do 384 different bar code I'm currently
talking only about generating virtual
reads I'm not talking about taking this
virtual reads and making assembly out of
this virtual reads it will be complete
so I'm simply talking about a new
technology to generate virtual reads
from humans I'm not talking about
assembling this virtual written to the
general and I don't have currently
aspiration to assemble I have a
different aspirations that I will
explain
mmm that's good anyway so
anything I can any I can question I can
answer my fault my fault but Mike in
flipped class it would be perfectly I
wouldn't be complaining about speaking
Chris you were ready for 15 minutes
being exhausted and I didn't even speak
for three hours okay
he has a result and everybody who worked
this metagenomics assemblers realize
that this is amazing so pleased upon and
as a metagenomics people at mentor
instituted rule in call versus data Mike
Snyder just published a paper in nature
by Tears
first metagenomics assembly this is a
total County Clerk says five cables that
many kinetics of the slabs so we get
pieces of metal genomic assemble data as
good sometimes better is an assembly of
calculated genomes from metagenomics
assemblies which is hundreds of genomes
in the sample why I'm except like we are
excited about this is look at this
cumulative length of all context of all
reads your children's from different
species just to give you a reference
point for human meta-genome in a single
experiment 150,000 to long Creed's this
total lands 826 megabases
some people don't even want to assemble
them further it's already amazing amount
of information but of course we assemble
them and when we assemble them ourselves
I am NOT going to talk how to assemble
this reads because it's trivial it's
very accurate to entrees and that's what
we get with is for community lengths of
lawn context and why creases excited is
because
ability is captured from rare species
because it has and this is like for
human microbiome which is extremely well
studied China 18 beans which means 18
genomes in the mixture
who is that more 75 percent identity
promotion bean so in in metagenomics
Linga when I give them assembling I give
context they need to figure out which
context go together and in the last five
years they were using Binion approaches
that basically look let's say
tetranucleotide composition or coverage
or whatever to figure out so presumably
if crease is correct this 80 bins are 18
new genomes individual genomes in human
nature and in Baltic Sea just an
enormous diversity but I am excited
about the small-time boxer yes will be
in context up please beans can't accept
us through space to true space use deep
brain graph approach there are two parts
fortress panes first assembly can take
from a single barcode then after you
generated virtual read assembling this
virtual reads into completion for both
parts we use the brain graft assembly
anyway this is my most exciting same
this is these are just code words for
different type of natural products this
is a very potent antibiotics anti-cancer
drugs like hepatitis
we eat it every day sound like line
typically attorneys envy it every day
because it's one of the most common food
preservatives safe and look at the
number
of the same let's say Baltic Sea you
metagenomic assembly through genome
because we know how the centerpiece look
like genomic makeup
there's only sink left finally for us to
generate spectra mage the spectra to
this element in the genome because it's
well assemble and find how this drug
actually caused this I should say
natural product because not not all
natural products are dragged some are
simply used for communication this as a
bacterial I think I'm done I mean there
is more I can talk about but I ran a lot
of time there is a whole in other
sections that I could just keep because
you don't want to talk about this this
is general methods of integrating
genomics and proteomics that is
necessary but it will skip it also so
there's a important people that
currently participate in this project
and these are people from space team
that were responsible for different
aspects of developing space and these
are our collaborators who a lot of fun
to work with
that's it I think I almost yeah almost
on time
Russians
it looks like everything clean I know
I'm gonna break those come from these
natural proteins natural products some
of them are not protein some of them are
I don't know leap it so whatever I'm
thinking evolutionarily I mean I can
understand how antibacterials antivirals
anti-cancer is this just a fluke where
is the release of evolutionary matter of
man where plants getting cancelled it's
definitely it's definitely a fluke of
nature so what does this product is
these are molecular bullets that have
often have very general purpose action
for example drills a membrane and when
like this guy's basically they dive in
the most exotic places in the world in
Papua New Guinea they collect samples
and then they have panels and they
actually most interested in anti-cancer
drug of cancer cells and normal cells
and the since they're looking for is
whether these guys kill cancer cells
more quickly than normal cells and they
have this therapeutic window notion
let's say if they find something that
kills cancer cells 1500 times faster the
normal cell they excited and the good
often go to us and after the codes this
and invest Africa's but they have no
clue in the beginning why kills cancer
cells
for many for many of them it is not
known for example I don't exactly know
what is bleomycin
mechanism of actions and through famous
famous drugs
what is tara famous anti-cancer drug
that actually goes back to 1960s that
became more scandalous drugs and war
because it was destined tempt is the
miracle drug against against so I mean I
I don't remember correctly and then it
let in deformities and pregnant women
and the drug you you remember my and
then it led to deformities JT JT Toledo
my and it was shelved it was shelved
completely in them in the last ten years
it become once again multibillion-dollar
drug because it had if it reply properly
and to certain people it actually works
very well so Nia honey and was not known
for this drug for definitely when it was
discovered it wasn't known
by diving no no the reason they look
most of natural products today come from
the ocean and there is a natural
explanation for this the diversity of
life in the ocean is by an order of
magnitude higher than the diversity of
life on earth at least here maybe a
Barnea island there is some competition
but they basically go to the most
diverse parts of the world to search for
this compound and the reason that
there's more diversity of the ocean is
visit less mixing I'm not prepared to
answer this question but I'm sure if
Bill Garrick was asked he would answer
only on and Gary was able dance
but look look the most of vertebrates as
far as I know are fish right there are
more fish among vertebrates than any
other species probably more species than
all together which tells us something
maybe it is quite diverse
what vertebrates